a new type of war has emerged
information warfare this activity by the
Russians is going to go down in history
as the greatest covert action campaign
in the history of Mother Russia news can
have real-world consequences it's a
danger that must be addressed and you
have to be the ones to do something
about it or we will last October both
houses of Congress grilled the attorneys
for the tech giant's Facebook Twitter
and Google about Russian meddling and
so-called fake news you have been
identified as the major distributors of
fake news we are not gonna go away
gentlemen Minnesota senator Amy
Klobuchar has already introduced a piece
of legislation aimed at more tightly
regulating online political advertising
the honest ads Act would bring
transparency and accountability to paid
political advertising but that only
addresses a small portion of the problem
a Russian troll farm called the internet
research agency produced thousands of
unpaid posts using fake accounts and
Facebook groups that targeted hot-button
issues like race and immigration their
strategy is to take a crack in our
society and turn it into a chasm and
it's not just foreign misinformation
some lawmakers want better policing of
sites like Infowars the Austin
texas-based conspiracy site run by Alex
Jones a short time ago on Twitter if you
clicked on the hashtag NYC terrorist
attack the top tweet links to an info
war story with the headline a mom
I warned de Blasio about New York City
at terror he was too busy bashing Trump
do you have a responsibility to flag
something as this was fake news we see
our users do that a lot we are an open
public platform where you must feel like
you have some responsibility we are we
are deeply concerned about that and
figuring out ways we can do it with the
right balance while Democrats seem
concerned that tech companies don't do
enough to police content on their
platforms Republicans and conservatives
have expressed concern that they do too
much to cultivate their users news feeds
your power sometimes
do you consider your sites to be neutral
public fora google should be regulated
like the public utility it is to make
sure it doesn't further distort the free
flow of information with both sides
increasingly suspicious of big tech the
regulation of online speech seems
imminent the specter of fake news and
foreign propaganda posing as factual
reporting is a complicated problem that
many lawmakers seem eager to tackle but
as president Trump demonstrates on a
near daily basis what constitutes fake
news is often in the eye of the beholder
you are fake this isn't to deny the
existence or importance of things like
facts but to say that handing the
authority to determine truth over the
government officials could be disastrous
it's important to remember that being on
Facebook or Twitter or YouTube is still
a voluntary activity because customers
can always log off these companies
already have strong incentives to keep
their platforms relatively free of bots
and trolls and to improve the user
experience through actively curating
content what we're trying to do actually
is provide each user a personalized news
feed that will be the content that's
most interesting to that user treating
social media as some sort of public
utility is quite simply a power grab
that all but guarantees politicians and
unelected bureaucrats will decide what
information should appear in Americans
news feeds and would likely grant the
government even greater access to our
private communications than it already
has are you intending to turn over to
the committee any kind of direct
messaging that went on among the
different accounts messages are the
private communication between our users
and so we take that privacy right and
responsibility very seriously we don't
want to put ourselves in the position of
being the arbiter of truth we don't
think that's a tenable position for any
company or industry it's probably true
that Facebook Twitter and Google aren't
in a great position to be the arbiters
of truth but the government is in an
even worse position this isn't the first
time governments have tried to control
new tools of mass communication much
like the Internet the
advent of the printing press provoked
panic and backlash among the elite
institutions that disrupted America's
the very first newspaper was shut down
after a single edition because it spread
rumors about the sex lives of government
officials and published what the
colonial government described as
uncertain reports or what we might call
fake news and for the crime of
publishing without a license the
government imprisoned and later ran out
of town another early colonial newspaper
editor James Franklin older brother to
Benjamin Franklin who went on to run
that paper a few decades earlier John
Milton famously criticized the British
government's regulation of materials
produced by the printing press writing
in 1644 that truth and understanding are
not such wares as to be monopolized and
traded in buy tickets and statute
instead better to let truth and
falsehood grapple why was this false
content allowed to remain in place there
was a small amount of tweets relative to
the size of the platform but impressions
of tweets calling out those things as
fake or eight times as large granting
government even the slightest control
over the free flow of information on the
internet under the guise of fighting
falsehoods will ironically make more
difficult the task of discovering truth
some level of fake news misinformation
and trolling might just be the price we
have to pay for free and open discussion
[Music]